yeah you know went welcome to this video
GC arise III okay come on c3 yes yes I
just play the most passive setup that
you can imagine instead of something
interesting with d5 of course it's very
solid and tough to break down but so I
totally fail to see why people play that
way okay I had an idea with Bishop
basics you know it was a pretty simple
ideas and maybe you can somehow play
Queen takes northern density 585 i still
have no do you find yeah this is
selection of the proper way this kind of
opening should be punished yeah I'm
sorry I'm always very opinionated about
that but as I absolutely see no point in
playing like this with why I mean just
play in the most passive session instead
of I mean what exactly is wrong about
playing this it's clearly the better
move than III or c3 and it's not like
you're losing or have any problem or
whatever it's just a better move and
people just want to bore you to death
with stuff like that I believe I don't
see any motivation other than that i'm
ok position is of course equal ish no
need to start the computer awesome yes
it's what white simply doesn't have any
active clan I may need I don't know what
you should do here and I could be one or
something just for fun that's what does
the engine suggest before although that
start to aggressors before yeah well
this isn't a good idea you kind of self
pinning I can also play d 5 foot
and yeah okay after that you're
basically doing Queen takes that's also
defines I can switch it on election like
win the peace and yeah that also
includes a piece yeah again I'm sorry if
you feel somewhat offended by my
opinions there but i assume play as
simply a despised playing like that III
see three against this kind of openings
which is that's not proper the proper
way of playing ok guys thanks for
watching